we absolutely want to engage with
president biden and his team
but we do have really significant
reservations
regarding a global minimum effective tax
rate that is at such a level
that it means only certain countries and
certain size economies can benefit from
that race
we have a really significant concern
about that do you envisage in you know
five years time 10 years time there'll
still be an irish 12 and a half percent
corporate tax rate yes i do i do
anticipate that there will continue to
be a place
for a rate such as this and for low
rates are you proud of the 12 and a half
percent
tax rate in ireland i'm proud of the
part that it has played in our economic
development
uh that for a a country of our scale and
size
uh that we were um able to grow our
economy that were able to grow
over many decades but i always make the
case
when debating our 12 and a half percent
rate that it is now
only part of the competitive offering
for an economy like ireland's it's part
of us
in light of the the northern ireland
protocol and what's going on
uh with brexit what's your response to
for instance david frost and there are
others in the uk government who who are
calling on the eu
to reconsider this not to take such a
purist view of the paperwork and checks
uh at the border minister frost and his
team negotiated this protocol
the pros call on the treaty was passed
by the house of commons
and the protocol was needed because the
form
because of the form of brexit that the
british government wanted to implement
which we respect that's their sovereign
mandate
but in their exercise and their
sovereign mondays it's equally important
that our membership of the european
single market which is also an exercise
of sovereignty on behalf of the irish
people is also recognized in this debate
but the protocol itself is needed and
is is i believe
um something that could yet play an
important role
in the years to come would you concede
that it's
it's not going well well there are many
different tests
regarding the protocol of course one of
my tasks
would be as a member of the irish
government is do we have a border
between northern ireland
and ireland that is hard in nature and
secondly
has the implementation and execution of
brexit
in any way materially affected
ireland's membership of the single
market and neither of those two things
have happened
so i made the case for those tasks and
how the protocol passes them
you know how how soon do you think
people are going to have to wait to be
able to travel without restrictions
either either between the uk and ireland
or indeed elsewhere in europe i i i
am hopeful that as we move through the
summer and by darth as i mean
particularly as we move
um through august and then maybe a
little bit beyond that maybe after the
summer
for some countries that we are going to
be able to make big progress
in opening up travel to the united
kingdom and within europe and the
european union again
the caveat to it is our vaccination
program
in order to get to a place where that
kind of mobility
is allowable we would have to be
approaching a
you know well in excess of a majority
being vaccinated it doesn't sound that
imminent
though we're not at the moment talking
weeks
that is the case and i go back to the
simple metric
i mentioned a moment ago which is where
we are with vaccinations